Previously, we saw that a couple of thoughts
were puzzling Nora. And we mentioned that
Calculus was the key to answer them.
She wanted to know that when we drop a ball,
how we can find its speed at an INSTANT…
And while thinking about this, she had another
strange thought. She was convinced that
mathematically
the ball should NEVER reach the floor. This
thought has puzzled many people for centuries
and it is called the Zeno’s Dichotomy paradox.
What are your thoughts about these problems?
There were 2 more interesting problems we
had discussed. Let’s say we are standing
on a cliff. Then what is the best way to throw
a stone such that it covers maximum distance?
And the other problem was how we can find
the area of any shape, especially whose boundary
is made up of curved lines.
We know that Calculus gives us the answers
to all these problems! The question is ‘How?’
First, we will focus our attention on these
three problems. And for this problem, the
one for which we need to find the angle at
which to throw the stone, we will have to
wait till we gain some additional knowledge of calculus.
Let us move on to a new page and start with
this interesting thought puzzling Nora. She
thinks that mathematically, the ball should
never reach the floor. As the ball falls,
it has to first cover half of the distance
between its starting position and the floor.
Then it has to cover half of the remaining
distance. Then it has to cover the next half,
and then the next half and so on.
So the number of steps the ball has to perform
never ends. Another way of saying it is that
there are INFINITE number of steps the ball
has to perform. Beware of the term Infinite.
Always remember that Infinite is not a number.
Infinite just means something which NEVER
ends, or something that is limitless.
Now to perform each step, the ball takes some
time. Since the number of steps the ball has
to cover never ends that is there are INFINTE
number of steps, so Nora thinks the ball should
never reach the floor.
But, we know that as we drop the ball, it
reaches the floor in a few seconds. So where
is the mistake in Nora’s logic?
In order to know the time the ball takes to
reach the floor, we have to add all the ‘individual
time periods’ taken to perform the individual steps.
But to find this, we will have to add an infinite
number of terms. Let’s say we take our calculator
out and start adding these numbers. Then our
addition will go on and on, and will never
finish. And as we go on adding the number,
the sum will get bigger and bigger.
That is, as the ball continues to cover the
successive steps; the TOTAL time taken by
the ball will keep on increasing. Another
way to say this is the ball will take an infinite
amount of time to reach the floor.
But we know that this isn’t true as its
common knowledge that the ball will reach
the floor in a few seconds. It will be a well-defined
number! That means if we add all the time
periods taken to perform the individual steps,
we should get a number as our answer.
Yes, even though we can’t mechanically add
the numbers, we can show that the sum of these
infinite numbers is equal to a number .
To show this, we carry out a process known
as TAKING THE LIMIT. And this is the central
idea that Calculus uses to solve the problems
we mentioned.
To understand calculus, we need to understand
the concept of Limits first, which we will
cover in the upcoming parts!
To understand this paradox, let’s keep things
simple. We know that as the ball is falling,
its speed increases. But for simplicity, let’s
assume the speed of the ball to be constant.
Of course we will get the answer even if we
take the ball’s speed to be increasing,
but it will be a little bit complicated.
So, let’s say the ball falls with a CONSTANT
speed of half a meter per second. In reality
the ball’s speed will be more than this,
but we want to keep it simple. With this speed,
we know that the ball will take just ‘two’
seconds to cover the distance of one meter
and reach the floor.
So let’s see how much time the ball takes
to cover these individual steps.
The time required to cover the first half
of a meter will be one second. Then to cover
the next one fourth of the meter, it will
take half a second. Then to cover the next
one eighth of the meter, it will be one fourth
of a second and so on.
So did you observed an interesting thing?
After some steps, the time taken to complete
the subsequent steps will be very very small.
So as the ball completes the successive steps,
the time taken by it to perform the next step
will get closer and closer to ZERO. This is
an important concept. It is getting CLOSER
to a definite number! But remember it will
not be zero… Each step requires some time,
however negligible it may be.
We know that the ball takes 2 seconds to reach
the floor. Now we can show that if we add
all these values of time taken by the ball
to perform each step, the sum will NEVER EXCEED
two and will actually be equal to two.
Before we prove this, let me give you another example.
Consider this square. Let’s say the length
of each of its sides is one meter. Then we
know that its area will be one square meter.
Now let’s divide or split this area as we
did with the motion of the ball.
First we divide the area into two halves.
Then we take one of the two halves and further
divide it into two halves. So what we get
is two quarters of the square. Now we take
one of the quarters and again divide it into
two halves. And we keep repeating this process.
What is happening here? We will realise that
this is also a never ending process.
But even though it is a never ending process,
we know that the area of this square, which
is one square meter, will be equal to the
sum of the areas of these parts. So we see
that the sum of these INFINITE terms is equal
to one, which is a definite number. We can’t
manually add all these terms, but their sum
turns out to be one.
As we go on dividing this square, the area
of its parts get smaller and smaller. They
get so small that their area is very very
close to zero, but not zero. But because these
parts as a whole make up the square, the sum
of their areas cannot be greater than one.
So if we keep on adding the areas of these
parts, their sum will APPROACH one. The word
‘approach’ is very important here.
Anyway, I am not sure if you realised… but
you almost have an answer for the sum of the
time periods taken by the ball to reach the floor.
Look at the expression we had for the time
taken by the ball to reach the floor.
And look at this expression we have for the
parts of a square.
Now if we add one to this set of numbers,
it becomes the same as this expression. So
if we add 1 to both sides here, we get the
sum of these values as 2. Let me recap!
On the right hand side of this equality, we
have these numbers which are same as the time
taken by the ball to cover each steps. And
we get the addition of these infinite terms
to be two , which is exactly the time taken
by the ball to reach the floor.
So , Nora understood where she went wrong
with her logic! She assumed that the total
time the ball will take to cover these infinite
steps will be infinite. Remember what we mean
by infinite here. It means something that never ends.
Let’s look at a quick demonstration so that
you understand better. This is the expression
we found for the total time taken by the ball
to reach the floor right? Now let us try to
find the cumulative time taken by the ball
to reach the floor, for each step!
For example, after 2 steps, the time taken
by the ball will be ‘1 second plus half
a second’, and that is equal to one point
five seconds. Similarly, after 3 steps, the
total time taken by the ball will be one point
seven five seconds.
If we continue this for other steps, we see
that the total time taken will get closer
and closer to two seconds. As the ball covers
the successive steps, the time taken by it
to cover each step is very very small. So
even if we continue adding many time periods,
the total time will never exceed two seconds.
The total time taken will just get closer
and closer to two seconds.
This is an example to understand the idea
of the Limit process . We can’t find the
answer to the sum of infinite terms of numbers.
But if we keep on adding successive steps
we see that the sum approaches a number. With
this, Nora is not confused anymore!
We see that if we divide the motion of the
ball into an infinite number of steps, it
seems that it will take infinite time to cover
these steps. But we can show that as we add
the time periods taken in each step, the total
time taken by the ball gets closer and closer
to a definite number.
It’s similar for the distance the ball covered
too. We had seen how the distance was split
into infinite parts. It doesn’t mean the
distance is infinite. The sum of these distances
will APPROACH 1 meter.
And guess what, through this limit process
we can also find the instantaneous speed of
the ball. If you remember this was another question that
Nora had. We will discuss
it in the next part. See you there.